do you smell what my feet are cooking
and it is apparently hot garbage how
nice it is once of our Wednesday or I
four shirt I am in a hotel room because
I'm still on the road for hanging us a
the new travel series that mamrie Hart
and I launched yesterday there's a brand
new episode today at youtube.com slash
astronauts what a TV please go check it
out whoa whoa there are puppies in it
anyway today I thought I'd do something
fun and dumb what a brand new concept
here so one of my tumblr gonna ask you
guys for suggestions of people to
impersonate and I'm gonna do some of my
couch don't do that when you're wearing
a ring
that looks like that I don't even need
to stretch my knuckles if I'm just doing
impersonations out of my mouth I went to
my tumblr Nash you guys for suggestions
of people I shoulda personate and I'm
gonna do that for you right now let's
get into it
yes we can so there you go there are my
impersonations I hope that you enjoyed
these because they're obviously very
very good and I hope that you feel
inspired to never try to do
impersonations because mine have just
proven to you that they're the pinnacle
and that there's no way to outdo them so
I hope that you find a different hobby I
don't know not going to go check out how
USA on YouTube become such astronauts
wanted TV the second episode went up
today and has puppies in it Jesus Christ
that was impersonation of myself okay